good everyone and welcome to today's
meeting of the council just a reminder
that we are being live streamed on
YouTube the broadcast could end will be
going to our private session and then
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
engineer providing microphones again
today however you will have noticed a
difference this time not everyone has a
mic
in addition to what you can see there
are four rolling mines which have to be
used by anyone wishing to speak who
hasn't been a life who punch them as are
the fixed might you will need to escape
when you wish to see and a member of the
team will bring you in my
the same rules apply to both kinds of
microphone please indicate if you wish
to stick if you haven't fixed marketing
engineer will switch it on if not the
radio light will be brought to you by
one of the team
please speak directly into the mic they
are designed for the speaker to be very
close they do not work if the speakers
some distance away
the care requests that you do not stand
when speaking today so that you can get
as close to mind as possible
please indicate to the engineering you
have finished speaking if you're using a
fixed mic and please return the roaming
mic as a team when you finish with that
please don't rush your papers as an
order noise can be picked up
thank you moving on to the business
before us this is an extraordinary
Council we will consider those issues to
further down from the 12th meeting when
we've considered only one item that was
addicted value free
there will also be a report on the
senior management structure which is on
the private side
although at the very end I'm going to
sort the two items so that we take the
senior management structure as the last
piece of business
first item on the agenda apologies for
an absence there are quite a few
uh yesterday I have apologies from
councilor Hill answer a Cooper cancer
d-dravel cancer a fossa and the M Foster
comes with J for now to the B Lewis
that's okay which way
that's located
and cancel that we realized thank you
Jeff
thank you
are there any other apologies
[Music]
listen
thank you
okay Declarations of Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
peculiary interests and or other
interest Council groups freedom
right
um
[Music]
foreign
okay thank you
there's nothing to finish
any further situations to be made
we'll move on
minutes of the last meeting so we now
have the minutes of the annual Council
and you'll be a meeting which followed
it they are both held on Tuesday the
23rd of May 2022 I would like to take
both of them together are we happy that
they are a correct record
I'm happy to move them
yeah absolutely excited
all those who say that
any against
any extensions
the motion has been carried thank you
[Music]
on the 12th of September today these
will be considered that our next
scheduled meeting on Monday the 28th of
November
cheers announcements
we do have a few of the Slime Ranchers
Elizabeth II I have attended numerous
Thanksgiving and surgery games across
the district and Beyond
to pay tribute to her late Majesty's
life
on behalf of the council I am hoping
told the memorial service in February
and further details will follow
as you all know Ken Walker previous
challenge District Council performs over
passed away last August
I personally have not met him but I have
heard many good reports about the work
he carried out I am sure there are
people here today that would like to pay
a ticket
I will now ask councilor tracker to say
a few words
thank you chair
last weekend the balls over brass
Festival was held in shirebrook
during the festival people took time to
pay tribute to Ken and Freda Walker
it was emotional to hear the Applause in
a respectful remembrance of Ken and
freedom
both have been associated with the
festival for almost 16 years
District Council
the attack on them both in their home
was truly shocking
and has left a community devastated by
freda's Death
and now we have lost count
Gene and I had the privilege of knowing
Freda and Ken for almost two decades
they were a very special part
of a close-made circle of value friends
it was a time of lots of laughter
even though some of Ken's many jokes
could be a little corny
but I found them for me
Ken had a joke for every occasion and
was good at putting people at ease
this was a valuable skill when healing
through your service chair and consort
to bolsover District Council
a role that can held over several years
in spite of previous saying don't come
back from group meeting having agreed to
another year
of course Ken couldn't say no
I for one I'm glad he didn't
because Ken and Freda represented bowls
over brilliantly
both were there to be ambassadors for
their district and serve every single
resident with pride
in all the years on you can't he and I
only ever mentioned politics once
that's not bad going when we served on
the same strategic Alliance committee
worked on several steering groups
together and were involved in recruiting
senior officers
even though I was outnumbered
politically in our Circle of Friends
conversations were always about how
communities could be best served
you can it's always about putting people
first
when Ken finally decided to step down
from bolsover District
the council lost a strong advocate for
Shiro and The Wider area
with Kells passing his family has lost a
loved one
we even lost a friend
and the community has lost a person that
cared about them
and who respected him in turn
which is my sincere hope that he is
reunited with his greatest love freedom
Russian instance
[Music]
[Music]
45 years I think you're my first hear me
about it
and even then it is we're just like as
we all know it was just a lovely man he
got down for everybody and like you say
he's there but remember that that it was
difficult sort of
stop
foreign
time
associated
he wasn't available
foreign
went pretty good
so
much
um
thank you
thank you
um
very well thought after the community
and I think we've lost all the help
through the community for quite a while
actually
[Music]
um
thank you
although it will always be with Brent's
disability
although it will always be with great
sadness regarding the terrible
circumstances and go to the loss of
kennel with wine breathing I would like
to share some of my own memories
which is difficult to think of one
without the other
however today we are showing our
infections of can I first introducer
came back in 2005 into specific event
despite some political differences we
became a remain firm and loyal friends
but this is in my home on a number of
occasions sometimes for a meal with a
group of friends but sometimes for a
chance and a cup of tea
it was always one of
one of what we referred to as the Mr
chain gun of custom present chairs one
of his favorite annual events that he
attended was beating the Retreats at
Chatsworth we often channel to those
together and he was a passionate who was
passionate about the event
restrictions we hadn't seen that much of
each other of late but we did keep in
contact by telephone and sending
greeting cards to each other great
thank you
to speak
no thank you all for that
it's nice to have you decide
thank you
I'm pleased to announce that on Friday
the 2nd of December we are holding a 70
things Digital
World Council it is
your three course meal tickets will cost
35 pounds per person and we'll go on
sale shortly I hope most of you will be
able to join us in support disparity
thank you
to close as many of you are aware
Council Aaron powers can take rather
poorly so on behalf of the council I
would like to wish him a CD recovery
thank you
I Society
thank you and I want to start by
thanking all members and officers for
coming together to mourn the loss of the
queen as many of you will know that
there's a huge amount of work to have to
pull together in a very quick time frame
but I think everything went very well
and we really enabled residents to pay
their respects to their Lakewood and I'm
also really grateful for all about
hurricane Town campuses but I know lots
of lots of words over local
populations and various different ways
available for everything else so
um just a big bang theory
um I'm delighted that telemarket has
opened its doors on Saturday uh
following 1.9 million pound
transformation project opportunity to
visit myself uh a few times it's really
amazing to see see it finally come
together after all that and the hard
work and the construction period I was
there myself on Saturday trying out the
South Bay Area I'm pleased to say it
held up my weight was the concerned
himself so think about that a great see
so much interest as well there was lots
of people dropping by to have a look
around and sign up for membership and
normally that continued and I really
want to say a big thank you for all the
officers have been involved in that it
really was a great one team effort
involving lots of different conferences
and lots of different departments uh not
without a few bumps in the road I think
we're all aware of that but we got there
in the end of Kenyan and Council of
Carol uh as a portfolio holders of
equivalent
as well as all the locals as well
Associates would really get to die on
the project being based across the road
there so thankful for that on the sake
of the streets but I'm really pleased
that we've been successful with our
Droid fit for 420 000 pounds and thank
you to the BCC and we've talked to have
supporting that and we're likely to use
this Advantage proportion of our uh our
allocation of that funnel towards the
refurbishment
this was supported by a lot of young
people in that area and you know really
value the Escape path
so really pleased to hope to be able to
progress on that and obviously we'll be
keep everyone updated
um our traffic investment plan for the
UK shared Prosperity fund was in
submitted to government and that details
how we intend to use our allocation of
2.5 80 million pounds over the next two
or two and a half years and we're
already working very hard the delivery
on that we've got a key focus on parts
and play areas public well shop Frontage
cycling and walking infrastructure and
Community halls and facilities and
really that key priority with that that
funding is to ensure that it's youth are
really visible improvements for our
community so the residents can really
see firsthand on the lawsuit for the
benefits that it's bringing
um in July we also submitted our bid for
a 17.8 million
[Music]
[Music]
Bay Area
um we're not sure yet whether that be
successful in the next few months but if
we're not successful this time we really
use that as a basis for future uh
digital funding and hopefully
um
through our work on the Armed Forces
government we were recently awarded the
Gold Award that starts with initiative
employer recognition scheme now we've
Wanted only about 550 Employers in the
whole country out of about seven million
words to have won that so it's an
absolutely amazing achievement and would
put alongside the likes of Jaguar uh
means and several others and even more
impressive given that we're a public
sector organization who you know fairly
advertising resources and constraining
resources and and being able to achieve
that status is really really
specifically and the demonstrates our
commitment to support these armed forces
and I want to thank the particular
cancer as our Armed Forces champion and
Steve Williams our nominated officer for
all of their work
I'm sure members will be aware that an
in principal agreement has been reached
between the four Puppeteer leaders and
the government for the evolution dealers
it's worth 1.14 billion over 30 years
but will come with an elective mayor and
I know I've been into focus on that
including my own
um but the New York very clearly not
about local government reform and
there'll be no changes to any of the
council boundaries or responsibilities
and that is written into the evolution
here itself but we will consider that in
more detail that we unfortunately
November
[Music]
delivering the commitment so we set
ourselves uh three and a half years ago
now I'm pleased to say that the only one
majority of the things that we wanted to
achieve have been delivered and there
are a handful of items so outstanding I
know that officers are working hard on
these but we're acute conscious of an
Administration that the council ban was
written
um you know almost in a different world
it was prepared with uh previously
living crisis and three several of the
key projects that we're delivering now
we didn't know about the tech assembly
at that moment in time uh we didn't know
about variables and things like UK SPF
another project so I think it's an
opportune moment really for us to look
forward to the remaining uh several so
months of the administration and we feel
as a cabinet that there are three key
priorities to the council the first is
obviously continuing the day job we've
got to continue delivering first half
services for our residents and we're
ensuring that delivering those
efficiently effectively as you possibly
can secondly the cost of living crisis
and supporting our residents and
businesses through that and I know that
there is an emotions on the agenda so I
went I won't talk any detail yet on that
one and then the final one is the
keyboard here it seems like the town
deal it's the Leisure Center uh
transformation projects UK SPF we need a
laser sharp focus on those projects we
have key time scales to follow and
deadlines to to reach some really direct
results to make sure that we get those
projects over the line and that's what
we intend to do overcoming agreements
clearly there's sorry come in seven
months clearly we've not forgotten about
the council plan but it's certain
opportunity to set the priorities moving
forward and that's it
thank you
just to confirm that there are no public
questions Cancer Treatments basically
okay okay
don't throw me off
just to confirm that there are no
questions from the public and writing
six there will move States questions
from Members under procedural 9.2 as you
can see from the agenda we have four of
these marked A to B and I suggest we
start with question a
maybe this question made and the answer
of shipment to councilor ready in the
capacity is portfolio bondage for
Housing and Community safety
thank you chair um I will say at this
point since
my question
um
or cabinet members and then we'll
receive an answerable staff I think it's
questions
a lot more instead of you know
that which is what's happened in this
case
um
[Music]
but that's all right
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chat
um so recently I've started doing some
work with the Charities of the national
travel Foundation under the national
trainer Foundation was founded in 1992.
it's an organization that aims to
provide help support and advice to all
those with forms of tremor irrespective
of age the foundation is a charity
dedicates to people with trellis and its
mission is to provide advice support and
publish information and promote research
so there are numerous types of trellis
that affect individuals of all ages and
the reason for me working with the
national Center Foundation is a personal
one last October I was diagnosed with
what is called an essential tremor an
interstate children is considered to be
one of the most common neurological
movement disorders and it may surprise
the council and our residents to know
that it is estimated to be eight to ten
times more prevalent than Parkinson's
disease
last time is the most common this
evening the elderly essential tremors
can affect people of all languages in
fact babies can be born with an
essential tremor and there are many
people who like me who have started to
notice their tremores
I started though
I started notice in mind that around the
age of 14. so I suffer from a constant
Tremor in my hands that can vary from
day to day on a good day I'm able to
function without issue but it's a good
person the social anxiety before being
diagnosed was terrible often people who
suffer with an essential tremor in my
age group will be met with comments
suggested in heavy drinking or words the
everyday small tasks that people take
for granted can be a huge challenge for
individuals the literally a great
advocate of the national Timber
Foundation is the actor Rob Mallard who
plays Daniel wildlife in Coronation
Street
and it was an absolute honor this
weekend so it's in the National Trevor
foundation's open day in Liverpool with
rock this was a great event that
showcased that by support lots of
information Phil sufferers health
professionals and others and it was my
pleasure to meet with Rob and talk to
him about the ways that we could spread
awareness
there are many people who will be out
there who will suffer with the Tremor in
a state of confusion and social anxiety
I would like to ask the council if it
would support the national Tremor
foundation in their efforts to spread
awareness of trainers and provides
advice and support for those who need it
thank you
[Music]
thank you uh thank you president
obviously
concerned about our social studies
um
[Music]
thank you for that and yeah I'm happy to
commit something after Pharmacy
um
come up with some relevant campaigns and
social media
um
[Music]
uh today with any members would like to
take uh
the recipes
thank you for the question to see is
from councilor Jim Burton tonight
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Financial year foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of the queen and obviously should any of
the business arrive we won't hesitate to
call another
um
council is not the only decision-making
meeting
uh cabinet continues to be monthly and
obviously lots of the business
um you know he's a cabinet level of the
full Council level I am aware that there
have been some postponement of
pursuiting meeting so I understand that
they are postponement rather than
cancellations uh that's what I've been
informed and I don't think yeah
[Music]
thank you thank you
um foreign
um that's not asking what the work was
John on the first of all Collective work
not related to contributions
so why was he unable to presented that
he said his business
to get the to get the business run it's
just that the naturally the progression
of meetings you're not going to hold one
in August of calls and there was some
concern around the obviously some in
terms of Liberation so you know a lot of
people do go away so it would have
helped the audience meeting
um you know I'm sure with a question
complaining about that so we're a little
bit sort of down to whatever view I
think to be honest I understand that
there were several items on the agenda
that were being worked on but they were
already the other issues around the
chamber we were hoping to have uh some
of the works of the chamber prior to
that hopefully that's not happened but
um that that brings an extra
complication obviously we don't intend
to cancel meetings that's not what we
want to do we don't want to uh you know
the table as it is
and for residents as well so that's not
what we're about at all it's just I
think the important in these cases is
just in a uh you know accommodation
circumstances
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
what the cabinet canceled how much of
the 24 million played across the town
deals and has now been sent or committed
including detailing how much has been
sent unemployed external Consultants
and yes there's a 24.1 million can be
opponents so far
9.41 million has been committed and with
7 million is the Charlotte Park Leisure
Center 150k for a railway station
150k for a low carbon energy capacity in
160k for project management and finally
1.95 million for a low carbon Advanced
fund the only Spanish from that so far
of the 34.1 million it was 94k on per
project and program management
like most following paragraphs for
example Lee they're being used to one
the program management team lead space
between the Thunder and the council and
ensure compliance of public criteria
submission time scales and there's also
a project manager of driving the
projects forward from concept to
submission which is what that might as
well case and useful the initial grants
are 24.1 million was also supported by
252k of government funding for
specialist consultancy preparing
business cases and to refine the
original Concepts in the bid and that's
part of the assurance and talent process
to ensure each element demonstrates
buying for money for public spending and
it also develops the initial Concepts
into deliverable cost of projects and
those are not skills that we retain
in-house such as economists custom
Consultants building surveyors transport
Consultants architecture
and in addition there was also 500 early
release from me right by the government
to enable immediate interventions such
as uh Demolition and site Remediation in
which we used to create two platforms
thank you for that it's it's good to
have an update can I just asked um
Council as well if we can continue to
receive updates then we could have
collapse attendance what I appreciate if
we could continue to regular updates
with regards to what's happening with
that money thank you
are responsible for running the project
and I do believe that our fake
councilors on that but um uh I'll see if
we can get more direct report to you as
well
thank you
[Music]
from members
we have construct motion eight there are
three motions of people in today's
cancers which are set out on the agenda
for getting their marks and alphabetical
order so we will begin with motion a
thank you
obviously we've seen the um
the European championships this summer
um and off the back of that
um
[Music]
and they are seeing a massive report in
girls
um wants to play football which is a
really good thing
um but what defining is that the
progression is quite difficult I think
it's a long period where they uh
football club and a disparity and what
they have to pay to send the bill to
football in the Sheffield United because
it's massive for example boys that don't
there you don't have to pay anything for
kids
250 pounds a year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um due to fa rules and
um for example the diagnose of an
incredible job
um turning what was some derelict the
horses along with him basically and it
said it's a fantastic football area and
they are wanting changing rooms on there
but there's the difficulties the whole
plane group that we've got to go down
September and uh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I'm sorry
thank you David
thank you and thank you for the
promotional cancer anyway
um
again with this sort of logical area
um I'd just like to start by sort of
making my congratulations to lionesses
was a great match and I think it was a
very positive tournament across board
which encouraged lots of new fans and
hopefully new fans and also enjoying
sort of getting people into enjoying the
heads and playing football too
um I'd like to mention as he's mentioned
in the nations in Council really
originally that sort of our
congratulations
[Music]
but also trained and we've also worked
at our Leisure Services
behind this motion and several members
of my family and friends face
I was like during during the Euros to
realize that women's football history
didn't happen
in that family but also I was standing
by some of the stories that came out to
lionesses and also the effective family
Professionals in the 1920s for 50 years
having said that though I think that
nationally and locally as you've
mentioned that's a fitment that we are
progressing in terms of
um participation in the sport so
obviously we want to support people
um I understand from the local I say but
the girls and ladies believe me
celebrating a strong season as 50 equals
25 reasons
as a whole in terms of recognizing what
we've mentioned about facilities
available there are various forms of
Grants to both emails across the sort of
County from the sa support boundary
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so whilst I've completely support the
growth of women's football I also
support increased access to many
voicings as well and I've been
supporting helping local teams regard
so once I support what I think is for
many aim the motive of this notion I
personally cannot support emotions vary
but I think you've missed some key areas
of development for instance we need to
be encouraging access to All Sorts
practice for all for all genders
abilities but also disabilities as well
so I think that's what we're aiming and
working to do centers and sports
facilities and we'll continue to do but
I do also commit to see how we can
support other sports facilities
providers such as Parish chances
but yeah thank you Council Barker
yeah thank you uh yeah yeah I think uh
what is that JavaScript
and I think we'll flagel uh yeah and I
think the other way
Scouts have been working the last two
years with the Derbyshire ladies and
Galas League and
well that that the end here was that of
all that will be the Derbyshire girls
and ladies week at the moment like I say
now that could travel to Derby today or
Sheffield there's nothing we haven't
gone to base in Northeast at all this
big as though we should not give North
get the field and all that area so they
really keep getting on board with us so
we can establish something on that
vehicle or if you legal field uh that
will be dead
the girls and ladies they put the design
for them by then so that's where we are
I mean there will be ultimately it's
been up for others Charlotte uh
but it's been my ambition Cromwell the
other beaches northern build uh during
the league whether it's girls uh the
boys so it is when we are well done that
line and obviously our fully support
because
you didn't know anything about this book
that you'll put this on me agenda
because it is something that well well
me again and you have to passionate
about that we want to make this happen
uh not good for Northern North but the
Northeast here so they're old and we're
leaving Charlie Park so we don't
duplicate yourself because it's not a
million miles away so hopefully it's two
or three years time we'll achieve all
this foreign
thank you
thank you chair
um very congratulations tonight well
[Music]
um I'm a little bit surprised by uh by
Council hughley's comments because while
we have a part of the talks of Landing
or while the other way to level up we've
started to invest in the areas
performing short and of course the
women's aspect of football is the area
we're just holding short
um so her response whilst I am so
emotion of it it does kind of like the
spirit of the first
um so it would be nice if it's a concert
if we will join ourselves and supporting
this motion thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
yes so yeah I'm not sure Charlotte's
response was quite uh understood that as
council's Arthur's demonstrated we've
been working on this already
um supporting North Winfield in that
case the supporting other councils and
um
uh you know the the one with emotion is
it focuses cancels attention on that
specific theme and there are many many
other sports that we need to support as
well so it's not a case of not
supporting
um the intent or desire to support
football it's about as a council we have
to take a balanced view of all the
various uh demands on our time really
and our resources and this is just too
specific that's the only reason that um
[Music]
that uh
yeah thank you um
Lee on the spot here but I think it's it
will be known that our language service
is ambitious and well thought over
costly you know across the sort of
stakeholders in the small organizations
to develop an off-the-shelf uh type
approach to uh changing rooms that would
allow for uh kind of cross utilization
uh of the same facility which I think is
really encouraging and so I just think
he demonstrates that the point that
cancer pending made that we are very
much on the you know in the game on this
we want to promote and support but
actually I think we all felt that the
motion to limited uh and there's more
that we can do across the whole board
[Music]
[Music]
um but I say not one of your suggested
amendments like that but you're just
trying to plan it
for some reasons that I think we've just
made up to quite honest and I I like to
have seen some quite positive responses
to the notion that could have actually
pushed us forward and instead we've just
had a flat now
and I think well that's you know quite
bad really for the conservative group
just to say now rather than suggesting
any amendments which would have pushed
women's sports across the balls forward
um but I'll disciples along with uh
independent colleagues
um thank you
[Music]
uh we're now moving to the vote and I'd
like this to be done by roll call
and the monitor accidents
those in favor of the motion
those against
any extensions
the Motions defeated
moving on to the next motion
foreign
foreign
I think we're just going to add up how
many are actually here
okay I've been advised that we just take
the numbers as is and we will move on
okay
motion B
plus I thought at least
yes thank you Council
thank you Joe
um I think one thing that everybody in
this channel will agree on is that
normally establish a household Jewish
volunteers and that's across the whole
of the district
um the Community First Responders
as well the Handover times as possible
life and again that's outside of
people's control so the motion is the
request that for the council consider
that providing we're going to meet more
of the establishment responders to the
benefit absolutely everybody
and
yes it's a large amount of these uh the
United States
[Music]
thank you
I do believe
yes thank you
thank you
responding that is counted down
[Music]
yeah um I think first person to say
we're highlighting that we strongly
support the First Responders and
actually Echo uh
volunteer organizations generally but in
particularly the First Responders there
are some members of our uh group and the
conservative group we volunteered with
them for a number of years myself and I
know other games councils are also
supported them with funding through the
vendors Community leadership team
um and I'm absolutely Keen to learn more
about this request for funding I'm happy
very happy to arrange a meeting for them
with Steve Lee and a lot of cabinet
members should be Allen uh but I think
that's the last means of dealing with
this request there really isn't enough
information within the wording of this
motion uh to really sort of decide on
the stasis I think we need to build that
into that a bit more and understand
exactly how it's going to believe what
happens we'll be accepted how many uh
you know residents they serve for
example throughout the course of here
all those sorts of things and I think we
do have a duty to attack
Advance ensure that it's being used in
the right results and we're getting the
right outcomes that we expect and we
have existing Bank teams reactions but
also our voluntary Community Services uh
grants that we wish to do about 150 000
pounds a Year too and I do feel that the
motion
it's a bit of a dangerous better than
before Council to be deciding event
funding requests Without Really the
ability to put in somehow it's going to
be used to ask questions of these of the
people's uh seeking the brand had
actually asked that I can be withdrawn
on that basis I mean the appropriate way
to deal with this is to improve formal
mechanisms that have a meeting with the
officers and meeting themselves to talk
about a bit more and get in the skin of
it and then try to decision on that
basis
so yeah I would absolutely withdrawn if
not then I think we'll vote against but
we will absolutely
thank you
yeah I
[Music]
think that's a fair response I think if
you would
would get that offer up I think that's
the best way forward it is a president
applications like this is
the right to go away into that one uh
obviously we fully support the First
Responders that do a great job oh what I
meant to say well
uh yeah I think if you if you don't
ignore it we're just one I'm saying
because we don't want to be seen uh give
me again First Responders when you say
that
this approach Festival through and forms
of development if there is money there
if if you call the boxes so that's where
we are on this so uh add Echo that if
you withdraw it and take the offer up to
meet with for the First Responders with
the cabinet person and Alex and I think
that's it
thank you
[Music]
well overall
um on the basis of the sacrament to meet
with someone from the First Responders
thank you
uh motion C is concately Hudson and
Michael Barker
that's a hard song
okay uh obviously it will move on a
little bit since uh this month
[Music]
um
since it was originally submitted
producers
increasing inflation production uh but I
still think this is a relative motion to
submit I mean we're moving our changes
today
from the British in the society
uh another embarrassing and uh but we're
pairing with motion as is which sounds
that many people in naughty establishes
continue to struggle financially with
the best of living classes and are
living with fear of things getting much
worse during the course of this year and
months I have to believe that any
refusal by government to offer Support
over Rising energy bills and the just
focused on tax course but with nothing
worse than a holiday on reality
the answer is but the answer to the
responsive living process cannot be
simply further and out and and make
tacticals that's what favor the wealthy
and big business
Council will oppose any government
policy that safeguards the stock options
executive
over supporting the tourists in our
society and associated with the
presidentiality
cancer believe that much more must be
done to help residents and all the
establishes reflected Council resolved
to work with the violence sector to help
support families during this customer
willing crisis by working with Parish
town halls and other community groups
to explore the possibility of a
establishing we've got warmth down put
them in warm spaces around the district
for the use of residents throughout the
winter right for the new prime minister
calling her to freeze the energy price
now to ensure that people on prepayment
meters do not have to pay more for their
energy than others thank you again thank
you
foreign
we need to acknowledge that people
across the district are finding things
tough
I was contacted recently by a single
parent with three children
who have four pounds to her name to last
the whole month
it's not just social deprivation we also
have rural deprivation in North East
cerbership
more and more we're going to see
families of Crisis points
some aren't on the red line they're well
below it
let me share with you how I see
trickle-down economics
those who are facing desperation because
they are inspiring debt
to Farmers in my world tell me they are
facing bankruptcy
we know that depression among the
farming communities on the rise
and so is the number of suicides
results
families in crisis
people are turning to ways to help
Escape reality this includes alcohol and
substance abuse
it also includes gambling as a quick fix
because your look might turn
it never does
resolved people in crisis
sometimes crying
we now see increasing cases of effect
and shoplifting among other activities
that impact on us all
results
Society in crisis
it's not enough to stand idly by as a
council and say there is nothing we can
do about this
is not enough to say we're going to
write a letter to government
we need to find practical ways of
implementing action
we have a moral responsibility
when I set up Viper during lockdown
there were many cross-party Innovative
approaches to supporting our residents
Viper or whatever you call in these days
must come meaning to plan action for all
pragmatic possibilities to address the
financial Situation's impact on the
people we serve
we have a human crisis happening and
this Council was act now
we need an amended motion that sets out
what we can do to make a bigger
difference
including how Viper can be repurposed
to address these issues but every single
person in Northeast Armature
thank you
thank you
yeah is that working okay yeah
absolutely
um clearly this is the most pressing
issue for pretty much all of those
um yeah it doesn't affect people in the
same way that we've historically thought
about deprivation there are plenty of uh
to see that the affluent people who are
really struggling at the moment so I
think this really is you know it cuts
right through society and absolutely
there are many many residents
but I think for us there are a few
fundamental issues with emotion for me
the the Preamble at the beginning which
is political uh my view is that the
crisis customer crisis transcend
politics and at that time of Grace's
need I think our residents would write
the expense of support of side
artificial differences
the motion is also clearly out of the
date now in terms of the energy price
gap which I think we reflected uh in the
motion with the Goodman through some
announcements around that and finally
for us the motion doesn't go far enough
for a few months now there's been a huge
amount of work going on behind the
scenes and seeing your offices from
various different departments and
cabinet members exploring all possible
app options for how we can support our
residents and I clearly given the impact
on our own budget and our limited
resources to begin with we're never
going to be able to support our
financial support on a similar scale to
what government needs to offering but
what we can do now with the price tag is
in place is to support residents
businesses with practical advice and
solutions to help them keep their energy
uses and thereby their builds as low as
possible there is also much more work we
can do with our UK SPF funding and sure
it's been used in a way which helps
organizations to bring down their own
usage following up on the work that we
did during covert to support our most
vulnerable residents there is more that
we can do in a targeted way to support
them and that's exactly what we're doing
together with our housing Partners at
originals and importantly we need to
ensure that we are mixing against
mitigating against the impact on our own
budget
as a council so that we can continue to
deliver much needed and relied upon
services for our residents and therefore
I'd like to provide an amendment there
is a paper version
and share with your permission if we
could yeah
members to read through it essentially
the key changes are to amend and be
politicized and Preamble for the reasons
that I've outlined a few slight tweets
to the three original resolutions and
then the addition of several other
resolutions which are taken from our
action plan which is which are all by
all means not comprehensive at all there
are lots of other things they're doing
but those are the some of the key points
that we wanted to pull out and the final
resolution I think Fades into exactly
what censor back here is talking about
there's an opportunity there to
constantly review our approach and to be
pragmatic and to see different vendors
use there so I'll make a commitment for
the the word foreign
yeah okay
[Music]
all right
um
okay everybody and before we move into
the motion I just want to make quite
clear
the phone that's been asked to be
repented this is one of the reasons I
like a roll call so you do not go
through all this who are again
on this side our group have 18 members
on that side there are 17.
we had one member that abstained so I
will be given the cards and vote anyway
so the result is still the same I hope
that's good to everybody
that's not what actually important
though that's why that's the point I was
making it because the when when I when
those numbers have been read out you
said it passed yes and you did not give
your passing vote one way or the other
because
one last question there the response I
got was true yes I was like
well it is where it is now and that is
closing the matter I will not take
anymore
that is why we have a roll call because
we will not have to have this situation
again
before
classroom
yeah
thank you right that's got that today
now we have an amendment before
[Music]
before I change
comments on this and I did seek to have
an additional factors about wiper so I'm
suggesting a slight amendment to 15.
so that we add where it says assist our
residents and businesses in the last
line there
comma working on a cross-party basis
um and then we have keeping Council
dated regularly along the way
I think that's an important part of
making sure that we do have that cost
party working
um by for however else it's done
whatever so that people know that we are
doing this together
right
[Music]
[Music]
about the Barker
thank you yeah
[Music]
we've decided we've done this is still
pretty cool Alex don't matter how we
look at it there's a lot of words in
there uh I think we we I can't
descending about working together and
ensuring the council to live all it down
and uh
you know about what the council is
already doing and what we can do but but
evenly be your Preamble if you love
there's still some politics in that so I
we can't support this as it's written
down and so if you've got to evolve yeah
I don't know whether we do a roll call
or or we'll ask for a recorded bow just
to be sure do you guys
uh
well that that that's where we are and I
know you've done all the way you're
putting that motion together and try to
be sort of the conservatory and all that
sort of stuff so
um
more than happy to wear with a Viber
group wherever we call it to try and
make things happen in Northeast
Derbyshire as best we can with the
officers and resources that we've got
because obviously it is a massive thing
and I think my happy thought to express
that really well about it it's a cycle
of decline if we're not careful people
are going to end up
uh taking a large and all sorts of stuff
but we don't want that so let's uh we
can't support this motion with exams
away
outside
thank you chair
um I actually Echo look at what cancer
well what council's background what kind
of stuff was there
um I think the particular line we have
an issue with is support the new prime
minister's only a price cut which we
feel just going to be here so that
that's available
um
one thing which which instead prior to
the adjournment which which causes I
think concert probably to most of us I
think most of us are somehows
um it's all right saying we're doing
this in the background but the parish
councils are actually working right now
and they're saying things right now
um they need that they don't need stuff
going on behind closer so they need to
know straight away so it's important
that this is that any work here is
straight away so that we can learn it
together there's no point in duplicating
things because that's not that's that
would be performance in regards and we
need to get these things right and
moving there so
as possible
thank you Council Barry
yeah um
and our local uh David's sentence around
they support the new prime minister with
the grass now that Christ happens is
very very misleading that price cap is
on the humans of energy typically
happening you speak to anybody in the
street and most people that you talk to
will think that that two and a half
thousand pounds is all they're gonna
have to pay
do not make it clear what it stands for
and how it's going to affected or
individual so there's no way on this
Earth I can put my name anywhere near
here
I think it's a damn shame that we have
to put on lunch in
now
thank you
so I don't really understand
how the changes are political the only
one I can see that you're eating
slightly political is support the new
prime minister's energy by step if it
really matters that much I've happened
to change that to note that and we do go
on to say but it hurts the government
because further so we're doing exactly
what you what what you set out including
trying to actual Equity
while I've lived through them is trying
to bring the original motion
you know at the end of the day it was
after then the the the the
changes that happens is it's still the
original word of emotions so things like
oh
so I think on that point we're clearly
trying to you know do whatever we can to
get this over line of across our
activities our quite prefer that you did
supports it on the unit of energy point
I think you're absolutely right that it
is down to the unit today and that's why
so many of these things are focusing on
and show you the others that they have
to bring bring down my energy usage and
you know they're not using more energy
than they need to so on the unit or
energy issue then yeah absolutely no
one's trying to hide the fact that we if
you average 2500
um you know build prices we'd be based
on it uh the increase the rest of the
motion is as far as I can see it's it's
political it's about doing doing the
right thing for our residents and then
the other point it's around three
minutes on now or not not involving
everyone
there's been a lot of work going on
um
they were just completely offline
announce a series of measures anyway so
it's it's no different for that I don't
really understand the the problems with
it so I just decided everyone who's got
behind it and support it because it
there is some good things in there I
think you've all agree there is a good
thing in there we can absolutely build
on it hope that we would you know we
we're both cancers
um so yeah I'd like to support it
yeah
thank you and we just like to point out
that we actually brought this motion
before any of the changes that your
government it wasn't through any fault
of anybody else's that this motion
wasn't able to be talked about at the
beginning of September
okay
since then your government
has made some substantial changes that
of course our finances of this company
to go into societal
one of those things that they suggested
as councilor barriers said is that we
all believe that we're going to have a
gas bill of only two and a half thousand
pounds and as we are now all coming out
of breathing for the Her Majesty we're
all beginning to realize the reality of
what that policy was we cannot support
this motion we'll talk about obviously
you've made a suggestion of changing it
but you've said this wasn't Eucharist
for our motion because it wasn't
political and if you read your motion it
is highly political for instance the
shared Prosperity fund my understanding
of the shared Prosperity fund is it's
partly about us coming out of the union
and what really we weren't going to get
from the what what when we were living
in you the shared Prosperity from you is
also part of the leveling up project
but my understanding of the shared
Prosperity problems it is less money
than we usually get to the district and
it has to be spent on more things
therefore this is a very political
motion and I want to draw everyone's
attention to the fact that this district
is going to get less money and we'll
have to do more things with it but of
course your quality of motion isn't
political is it so I can't mention that
I'm assuming we're going to have a
management of this motion that marketing
councilman Factor has made about the
five of them we take we do have to work
together we might disagree with each
other fundamentally but we all have at
all this District I must insist that we
recommend this motion include the Bible
so that we can all work together to help
this community I'm going out there as an
individual District councilor arranging
to meet my library to talk to my library
in Homewood about how we can help people
go through this crisis it would be
easier if I felt that the County Council
was on my side and helped me to increase
the hours of our library to make sure
people have a Whirlpool to go to during
this crisis that your government has
started as being a big part in making
sure
[Music]
oh
happens
thank you counselor on it
that would be perfect but at this at
this package it was most generously in
Europe so actually we're going to be
doing a lot better than some countries
and also in terms of the library just to
just to make it a bit clear to um
the library the music library in pillar
last is actually now part of a confined
Leisure Center but there's far much
football and there's also a cafe it's a
woman supposed to be anyway there's lots
of other people there have great
improvements not only perhaps 12 months
ago
[Music]
um
this this these motions and they um
we will support this but if number three
shortened down to urges for residents
[Music]
so I think if you support whatever most
of what's in there vote for it and
that's actually get something started
doing it
and bring back back or whatever it is
for now absolutely
appreciative that we're actually working
together to try and do something about
it
it's like being in a nurture sometimes
yeah
[Music]
I've already said more than happy to
change the word support and notes in
drafting the the amendment I would
repeat Consciousness
uh how do I not negate the notion and
the reason that that sort of sentence is
still in there although I'm really
worried with it is because I think to
remove the reference to the energy type
that I believe would negate the most but
if you want to change the note the new
energy
government I'm more than happy with that
and that's that's taking a neutral
position on that I don't mind
foreign
[Laughter]
that's depending
sort of slightly actually
um are we amending 0.3 or not sorry just
a
are you happy to note the energy price
down I'll have it proposal
all right
okay
and
we are going to call the discussion
we have the rights
off you go
okay
number three
thank you
we're just going to clear where we are
with the interview so we can take a vote
he's just can't find where we are at
because I think most of the soldiers
right so I'm talking on the amendment as
modified in number three to say note the
prime minister's Enterprise account and
to say working on a prospective basis
thank you
um yes so very happy to support this
amendment and and also very happy to be
Advanced and shipment's words actually
about also supporting it uh it has
become part too political it's very
unhelpful residents would believe be
upset with us for wasting time on that
that's one reason to and then move from
the first place in fact is to talk on
the issues facing our residents and what
we can do about them I would just say on
the Christ cap I think a flat cap would
be a bizarre thing to introduce not
least to my climate points as we
actually which I know to many of our
hearts the idea that you can use as much
as you want and not pay more than 2500
pounds the shopping and so a unit cap
has always been they think that's the
same pretty much across the planet as
well where they've introduce these
things
um I'd also say in terms of
to put to this point people being able
to communicate with the stock
Administration about ideas for this our
mailboxes are always open to anybody or
our phones that people want to call us
and suggest things and say what are you
doing about this and bend area and then
you thought about this
um absolutely I've heard uh various
things from local climate groups that I
that's that's the expense of what I've
heard really in terms of are you doing
this are you doing that and that's been
very welcome
um and one other particular thing that
has come out of it is when we've been
analyzing it and as as was mentioned
earlier it's a big Amendment because
it's a huge piece of work and one of the
things we identified is that our
residents are very much not equal even
within our Council housing and we've
done many thousands of external wall
installations now on the houses and one
of the targets that we are going to
focus on is people who haven't had that
yet which ain't there are 600 or so
um that will be done in the next you
know doing another two or three hundred
loan so focusing attention on those
people in particular because they want a
much harder job than somebody who's had
a well insulated house
uh and it's a huge number of that sort
of little couple little complexities
that that make up this share conspiracy
fund I mean a simple way to look at it
is anything that we do to avoid
businesses or residents wasting their
money on energy bills it all helps with
the prosperity and spent on energy is a
pound taking out the local department so
um you know it's again making it
monopolisful it's just about using that
Resource as best we can and so um
yeah it's a big piece of work to all all
helped welcomed to progress it please
and I'll um secondary Amendment thank
you
yeah
[Music]
nothing further I would say you know
really happy to go whichever way we can
uh to make this non-political we don't
want to be physical this is about
putting aside those differences you know
we have done a lot of work already in
the background but absolutely there have
always ideas from every single person in
the game and we'll keep doing that this
is not a problem that's going to go away
anytime really soon with it so yeah
and uh yeah I said at the beginning
right now this is just to vote on the
inventions
because
foreign
starting at the end of the alphabet
please could you tell me if I'm not G4
against sword Stony
right
councilor be right
Council Welton
Council tracker
Council shipment or Council Rock
cancer rugs
that's a row
running
that's reader
lots of plants
that's a big green
absolutely
Council Morley sorry points
that's a bigot
that's a lady
that's a Kerry
that's a Kenyan
that's the Jones
that's a Hutchinson
that's a heart soul
that's the whole
that's really cool
that's a
Dale well let's just keep it
that's the corner seconds
that's a class or Council Birkin
that's the battery
that's the Barker
Council Armitage
um
okay
24
14 events and one abstention the
amendment has three Carriage thank you
so we now need a vote from the amended
do you wish to do a recording coaching
this one as well
this is the substantive motion as
amended
the amendment
foreign
[Music]
that's a Pickering
councilor Morley
absolutely
that's a legit
cancer Lacy
Council Perry
that's a canyon that's a Jones
that's a heart song that's a Hancock
that's a whole
that's a Gomez really
because Elliot
that's the Dayton OH that's a Dale
that's a Cupid that's a Cornwall that's
a cloth or That's A Burger King
okay that's a Barry
Council Barker
that's the Armitage
foreign
[Music]
against one extension it's carried thank
you all very much
moving on to item nine
service of committee annual report
I would like to invite cancer on which
is just care of the committee to comment
on it and then give any other members a
chance to speak thank you
thank you
and this is not the political
yes I am sure
during the last Municipal year
but they're not intended to always
fights in detail but they will go over
the key areas
on the matter of complaints the council
received five complaints that related to
members acting in their capacity as a
town or a parish council and for
complete relating to an LED District
Council of one complaint related to both
a district and a parish council this is
a total of 10 complaints which is a
decrease from the previous year when
they were 18 complaints we received in
telephone so we do invest it
of these complaints nine resulted in no
further action being taken one complaint
resulted in the Council of being advised
to apologize and to attend a member
training event
during the course of the last Municipal
year it was the necessary to recruit a
new independent person
these recruitment exercises were so
successful that on the 26th of April
2021 Council was invited to appoint two
new independent persons in addition to
the already existed independent person
details of the council's pre-dependent
persons are contained within the report
at section 5.2
at the end 30th of June 2021 we think of
the standards committee a new code of
conduct of councils was considered and
later approved at the 12th of July of
July 2021 meeting with the council
standards schematic considered about
training should be undertaken on the new
code of Congress and the number of
training events will held for both
district and Parish councils towards the
end of 2021.
and that concludes are there any
questions not politically
I'll talk about non-political book I
thought everybody in this room will go
political then what is your way and this
is true please
purposely then
after all the paperwork I can't find any
report as to whether that counselor
whether it was did take bad diet and
apologize and did indeed attention to
them and someone pointed out to me in
case I missed it my classes again it
really exist where would it be recorded
where would it be shown
what did it happening
for myself
all right
thank you um and foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you chair um just from the point
that uh services
[Music]
so if one of these members sat in this
room is used to remember public or
racist but what we might be
the reports that we haven't won in this
Council are all in our lives and we
don't know who that person is
or you know
we don't know what it is
are we really saying that that's
anonymized forevermore and only
serenoids or whoever it might be um
it will be anonymized so where
somebody's knocked down to a breach or
they didn't it wasn't while they were
counselor or whatever
um I'm not sure if this one is
anonymized I'll have to go back
outside of my group
I'm sure Council officers are definitely
can say that and some District would
have something to say about it whereas
in this case it's been tossed out of
some kind of internal parts of this but
as we've seen since 2019 six councilors
have left the conservative group for a
variety of reasons
um majority of those and because it's
the same thing
and I think there's a real problem
the these things are not addressed and
if there's no official components so we
had argue that that might be a case of
those certain partners are afraid of
going down the official rules and
Reporting is this sort of really yeah
and I think that there is clearly a
problem for that many characters more
than 10 of the whole Council believe in
one group and I don't think it's right
it can just cut the top of some kind of
internal positive I think it was a real
problem within this capsule uh
furniture on a particular issue you
raise please remember the localism Act
and the complaints relates to the
councils when they're acting as
counselors it does not cover them in
their participant meetings
and that is a matter of law
so I'm sorry Sarah but when the
allegations are with councilors are
being bullied for Council reasons and
the intimidation is happening to so that
people vote in a certain way I'm sorry
but that is a council issue you can't
just say that that's not a transition
but its effect invokes in this Council
payment
localism Act and the system only affects
councils when they're acting as
counselors and secondly it's a complete
threat system so I can't do anything
until I have a complaint it does not
affect you in your private lives
means when you're in your group
and as I say that's a matter of law
I would say too adapt to that that if
any person has that sort of thing they
have the problems to take it to and this
isn't probably the place to discuss it
that's a very personal thing for them to
do
but that's very
yeah just a question really what
investigation is taking part about the
same place is property results and the
people have been informed what that
result might be you know it could be the
as a suspension or there's an apology or
whatever
and and say it was to be an apology so
to get a person who wants to have done
the action that they've done against
whoever else it was
should have made his apology but with
that upon me actually get pause when
it's doing that when the complaint was
in a public meeting
when would that apology be given back to
the person that was affected in the
first place or to the group for the
behavior of the person that the contains
about
um just to say the investigation this is
a two-stage process we don't investigate
that's the first stage we look to see
whether there's a potential breach of
code of conduct and I have to say of all
the communities we've had in the last
few years we've never gone into sorry
we've once going into a concert
investigation in terms of the apology I
take reports and we would look at the
circumstances of the complaint when when
the behavior contained of was married in
what environment and looked to make an
apology
in a similar environment which is quite
right it's a public meeting
has never been given
uh I've raised up with you before so so
um a list of classes and I'm still
waiting for the official apology
[Music]
okay
okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
give other members a chance to speak
that's a Factory's chair of the order in
corporate government student committee
I am a strong Advocate three scrutiny
system that is apolitical and puts a
good mirror to the workings of council
important scrutiny leads to effective
governance
I can assure you that the Audits and
corporate governance strengthenicity is
a robust forum
where the financial oversight and strong
challenge are key
section 3.1 of the report provides an
outline of our work during the Civic
year
it is a flavor of all we have achieved
I can assure colleagues that behind
every line of the tasks listed is a
meeting of healthy debates
mutual agreement and disagreements
positive engagement
and a no-so left unturned approach
recommendations where appropriate are
major cabinets for example improving the
investment strategy and considerations
about the long-term financial position
cabinet can rest easy knowing that our
committee will be checking progress
the committee strives to develop its own
performance and as a result completed a
self-assessment review in accordance
with the best practice
I am grateful to those colleagues who
have made a positive contribution to the
work of the committee
and thank you to officers who have
diligent approach is much appreciated
in particular during that's it for
Section 151 officer and Jenny Williams
head of internal audit thank you
thank you
as the Council of Tate is not here we
shouldn't move on to the care of both
scrutiny committee Council
an organization okay
[Music]
have you got something to say okay far
away
thank you
um I'll keep this for you because
um
section 3.3 the report provides an
interview
with the committee meeting on some
occasions various updates from officers
were heard on items which is
actually and the leader program
as well as closing up the solution units
um taking on the chair position our
point of the year uh count as instructed
students some of the community decided
to take the spotlight review of the
council foundation of the businesses as
outlined in section 2.3 of the reports
of the communities agreed to extend the
leader to the program into the work
streams to try to be Municipal here
broadly in the scope of the review from
the confidence for business education
which was totally important in the
context of the photos pandemic economy
and further economic environment
even if you have a full schedule
um I'd like to express thanks to all
colleagues which is very important to
all the officers of support have
provided
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chair
might have also a little bit larger than
the last term
as we tell at 2.4 again your report our
main review for 2122 was focused on the
ICT and transformation
what the director of transformation and
portfolio of the transformation provided
information to set the scene under any a
new BBC digital transformation which
then enable the committee to carry out a
number of interviews with a round range
of stakeholders as listed in Daniel
reports
Council had achieved in a short space of
time and how the pandemic and welcome
say had helped to share the accelerated
and accelerate the upgrade process of
Microsoft 365
cloud-based Solutions
the outcome of the process helped pave
the way for a committee report to
present four recommendations which I
understand it now being with the
government
questions are also raised in relation to
the members I.T and the future Focus
however a management review was already
underway so this did not fall part of
the main report
in relation to other areas item 3.4
provides further information on the work
carried out through the committee
which included the annual report newer
resources and organization development
with continual this provided by Sarah
Gordon on various employee related areas
as detailed instructional reports the
progress review of the transformation
program with further questions around
digital skills during the pandemic and
how the council had ensured that all
residents were served equally especially
where ICT may be a barrier the committee
received very clear information that the
council has and will continue to provide
communication to many different channels
and health assistance would remain part
of this
advising director of rig those holes
presented the committee with a detailed
breakdown of better operations and
provided information on the many
different areas of work they undertake
something very important and applied
outside the normal delivery of accounts
and services a more personal touch that
greatly helped our residents
the main committee focused for the
coming year will be on Plumbing
enforcement and how various departments
work together to deliver this important
Council will
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank the community members the officers
and all stakeholders who attended the
meetings for their time and dedication
to the council thank you chair
thank you thank you so many questions by
any of the members
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
any other comments
I know what she's doing
it's not going to be the same
okay
to be moved another show of friends
thank you
lots of 12 local office offer for
children and care and Care leaders
the local office of children in care and
kg is this is reported the leader of the
council so I would like Council Devils
to speak on it and explain without being
asked to approve today
thank you jet members will be aware that
I think quite a few years ago we
implemented the uh 100 discount on
council tax for Derbyshire cavies that
is candy was replaced by garbages for
facing authorities if you like
um and and I'm obviously I've been very
successful details I don't remember
doing that I react number but we've
supported not huge numbers of young
people but
um you know a few young people each year
and I know from uh you know from various
systems reports how caring in particular
disadvantage with a particular group who
are susceptible to death uh you know
they they need or they don't leave home
but they they end up in independently
far sooner than ambassador of new people
who
um I think the average age emotions we
could lose the family home but if it's a
little time we expect and yet obviously
um what what we did when we across
across the whole of that which are all
uh advances of the collecting Authority
adopted a policy of exempting the
garbage of care leaders and adoption
County Council for any garbage pair we
received outside of but outside of the
outership but aren't Exempted by that
Authority will pay for their cancer tax
what the the missing group if you like
are non-verbs areas so people who for
example were in the care system and say
nothing ship and now living at
Derbyshire they're not currently exempt
I think there's one or two other
District cancers within the within the
county who will just stopped the the
wording of that policy Joseph versus
care leaders rather than damaging
parents so in acknowledging that that
sort of missing group is still there if
you want to change the policies
the cost is is minimal as we say and the
benefit we see for those residents so
umend that policy just to get clarity
and I'm happy to move the recommendation
is there a second thank you Council
or Parker
political that I like it said it's a
really positive thing
[Music]
and I know that yeah
it's massive and a lot of lots of things
so the more that we can help them people
the better and I'll probably support the
the recommendations and that you said
about the damage
shipment
[Music]
thank you
um masterton city councilman is absence
here because she was a foster care for
many many years and uh
anyway so I've seen those circumstances
so and quite literally
um they are not for any any fault of the
foster care is just because the system
doesn't allow them to keep them outside
to other stuff going on with himself so
they really are turned out and that they
have to find their food very very
quickly so full of support this notion
it is
thank you
[Music]
messages
have been brought up in this area
nobody's care because there's no vets
available they get more out of the
country so because I know
I know this from the work came to do and
I know this is a fact so as we get there
and we get established their friendship
and then they want to live there then
responsibility because then if they're
not getting there
yeah yeah
thank you um yeah in that situation the
trouble we have is that we don't have a
national public service really that's
the fundamentals that you see you've got
lots of different counts of doing
different variations so nothing major
for example uh Exempted all characters
across the board regardless of whether
where the facing authorities in
Derbyshire we've got agreement for all
of the garbage Logistics and borrowers
to agree to the discount
leaders and Derbyshire County Council
took the decision to pay the council tax
of any damage carriers are living
outside of Darbyshire so they are
covered but if they if they live in an
area say like an option that has its as
they're going to abroad families that
establishes another area another area
so they are protected but really the
best thing would be to have a national
uh a national policies which is
foreign
by the 1980 and that was a situation
that abuse downstairs
transfer causes responsible Society
thank you is
yeah yeah
absolutely although I would say one of
the things that has changed is the duty
and all uh uh Aid to the same effects
um so that that they're doing a bit more
support amongst you know in career
people things like saying what would
impossible to completely right I mean
it's still these people still face a
significant challenge any extra support
foreign
you think
item 13 requests for a community
government's review for Stone Brewing
this is a request from Community
government
would like the monitoring officer to now
go through it before asking the legal
accounts to speak
[Music]
apparently yeah
um I've provided a report update for you
you shouldn't have a copy on your desk
this includes the petition itself and
match details as well as a proposed
timetable for the review it's completed
in time the elections in May 1923
the report outlines the receipt of a
valid petition asking for a separate
Parish Council for stone building and
sets out draft terms of reference for
that review
Council council is being asked to
approve the terms of reference so that
the review can commence formally
in terms of work that's just been going
on in the background and subject to
members decision to say a draft
timetable has been produced this is in
the update paper you have it is very
tight the approval of any new
Arrangements would have to be made at
Council on the 30th of January in order
to meet the elections deadlines
including the complete republishing the
entire electoral register the district
in February 23. this is a repeat of four
Publications register on the first
December thus changes resulted from the
reviewed it also requires a lot of extra
work from a number of officers meet very
excited deadlines whether to be a new
marriage Council for example at least
section 151 and finance would have been
revenues which have to separate
um
the review will not necessarily result
in what the petitions are asking for
Council can decide on the basis of
consultation evidence we see that the
current arrangements are appropriate and
make no change
the recommendations are on page 38 and
you would ask at the timetable in the
update is included in recommendations
rather than as a currently being
exceeded this could be by amending the
recommendation say included instead of
exclude timetable and also change the
data publication at the end of returns
furniture
thank you don't see you then yeah
um nothing really heard it throughout
obviously um if you want to comment on
we don't allow for this and do a part of
the
processors
but yeah we'll be happy to amend ask her
what what Sarah has
thank you are there any comments
these production
s
I was going to say no I can't I can't
give a guarantee it is really tight but
we will do anything possibly can to make
sure it is achieved
yeah just based on then what you just
said there then so if we go today and
the timetable is not achieved does that
mean that pure London I am Parish
Council it is
um Parish Council would act result for
re-election and then Stone Brewing
Parish Council then after the real
election even though we've just been
elected in May that is entirely the
situation you're trying to avoid in the
event that a separate Parish Council
comes into being the key date is
February for the new complication of the
Electoral register in time for the
elections
that were most considerably before may
not matter
no because the journey
s understanding of organisms that we
came to get it um
is
Council board
the cost of this I'm a bit concerned
about it's obviously looking at the
table with some questions
is that money that's going to be wasted
that could be used
just asking
thank you we have no choice about what
to do it by law we have to do it but the
kind of costs I'm looking at at the
moment is a process are in the thousands
and two three thousand maybe five six
thousands to organize public meeting
and that kind of thing
thank you there's no further comment can
I just have a show of hands to move it
forward
foreign
the current promises are published in
2018 and I reviewed every three years of
the last review
um
our sisters conducted a review and
presented an updated set of policies for
the licensing committee the updated
policies Incorporated both locally
identified improvements and the national
standards set by the Department of
Transport in their recently published
statutory taxi and private hired vehicle
standards the policy will publish from
public consultation and a final set of
draft policies presented back to life
because these changes increase the
safety of the residence
the main changes to be introduced are an
increase in the frequency of checks and
taxi drivers the introduction of new
checks for vehicle license holders the
policy will introduce more frequent
criminal records jokes more frequent
safarily training more frequent
disability awareness training and more
frequent medical tricks
others in addition to this is the policy
will also the introduction of criminal
record checks for vehicle license
soldiers
members start strongly that north east
south we should play their part in
raising the standards for taxing icing
across the country
across the county and the country and as
a result the general license committee
moved a recommendation that policies at
the same house adoption
um personally I think it's been a very
uh sound sorry piece of work and I'm
very happy to go with office
recommendation and propose in the policy
of Philadelphia
foreign
documents until I went on the website
and I found on the website it's natural
licensing policy that at least very data
it creates a lot of October 2022.
so this is going to do a license
activity according to that whether that
dates wrong
to discourse the CCTV at the future
meeting
which to me is Rapid Way Round I think
that should be a great first before we
get this doubtful agreed that policy
that that one paragraph had to then
742 paragraphs
it does mention that the rest of the
stuff have no problem all I think we
should be fair this uh this paper this
this belief until at least that meeting
has been at the licensing committee on
that day because there's a lot in this
about how the how the cameras are
supposed to work what what if were they
going to be positioned those in charge
of seeing all the other so so we're
agreeing something
exactly
[Music]
thank you we have actually got the
technical advisory Terry I believe
unfortunately that is a narrow
s
yeah okay and unfortunately that is an
error on the document that's on the
website it should say 2021 the CCTV
policy for taxis was approved in October
of 21 and it's just going through the
process of implementation and that will
be put in very shortly so we have all
already followed back to get that policy
implemented
[Laughter]
thank you
are there any other comments
thank you
um if you might recall debating the
future TV aspects of this
um one of the warnings that I gave at
that meeting was that it's all one of
those introductions and things but when
you hold the surrounding councils
uh evictating on this policy I would
have been born with me and then
um we've seen test fields are going back
on the news now so obviously diversity
we're going back on there now
what we need to do is we need to get the
Secretary of social transport on board
with our
Superior positive that I Because unless
they do people get license and test
fields
and ultimately we're actually losing
control then over those taxi drivers
because they're going to be elsewhere
there's enough
of the different doors
and I would like to amend this uh the
recommendation was for social contracts
contact the Secretary of State and
actually give them this policy which uh
policy but until we get them on board
with that I think we're just going to
lose control of the taxi drivers
and we really need to keep going all
over them and hopefully implement this
policy across the country it's almost no
problems we really need to get a
description sorry
I do believe that the motion before a
system just focused on CCTV
says
because even if even when we're talking
about safeguarding
um additional safeguards
etc those are the talk about those as
well
without talking about the whole policy
we need that whether it's government
legislation thank you I believe Charlie
yeah and if I can just clarify that the
majority of the changes in these
qualities that are before you today have
come from the statutory standards that
have been set by the Department of
Transport so there is already that
National Standard that they have set
recently and that will encourage other
authorities to follow suit and get these
things implemented as you said in the
CCTV is one that's a bit more of a
controversial topic and some authorities
aren't going with the implementation of
manager CCTV but most of the changes
that you see before you today do form
part of the statutory standards that
have been set by the Department of
Transport
thank you
is there any other comments
whether or not we've been able to
recommendations I'm certainly happy to
be related to the uh
absolutely
aware of that and I know that has been
quite a bit of lobbying around uh
fabulously to implement but you should
have to revise
yeah
[Music]
same thing about adding a recommendation
about that but also
um that I think we could pass this
policy today because the community has a
lot of work it sounds a little bit and
talk to that in terms of the actual taxi
license and the policy itself with
regard to CCTV
there are some issues still hanging
around about that and then as we know
the last slice of system that's requires
a good conversation around it and it is
a moving fee so we compare ourselves
with other Taxi licensing authorities
but I think we should agree to this
principle but we have any additional
recommendations
um helpfully agreed to but also it will
go back for a monitoring process through
the license activity so that we can
check on what's Happening and if we do
have to amend accordingly then we should
otherwise then I think this account
thank you
I agree I'm sorry I mean it has been
hard work there's a lot of work on the
internet
um and as far as I'm not aware taxi
drivers that have their taxes NO2 that
our Depot in Edmonton are already asking
they're quite involved here I think on
their side as well because it gives Zone
protection as well as the passengers in
the residents and we are supposedly
going to happen to our super Commons
team that our taxes have CCTV cameras so
people have insurance
well thank you
[Music]
okay here we go again you know we have
the motion put before you and I'm going
to ask
CNN look nothing else
thank you very much
item 15 Shelby Park Leisure Center
updates
and a short presentation giving us an
update on the Charlie park closure
Center by the director of growing
Fantastics so over to Matt Dalton
emphasis I'm sure
probably the right thing
um in terms of
um time sales I think I will
go to this at Canada and perhaps share
the slides
um after there are some visuals
um so between a mile or less there's a
little bit more reactive than the screen
on my drive and there's a video but you
might get it through on that one but
I'll quickly run through so
it's it's Council I think the last of
David Adam Charlotte was
January and A lot's happened since
January in terms of uh progress on
design
so a very quick reminder that's
Charlotte Butler Center as it stands
today
and then in January this recommendation
was uh would be by this Council
that's pretty good uh further worked on
design
and put it summary and so you can see
accountable contribution there there is
a seven million pound contribution from
Town Fund which is to say that has now
been secured and we've lived over the
council
Sports England there is a commitment for
1.5 million pounds of support towards
the project and we are at the final
approval stage with a letter concerning
the
the project meets four things and
strategic objectives
[Music]
and regarding a 3G football pitch and a
contribution in Regional in advance
towards that
[Music]
um
so that's the design team both go to on
streams
and the only sounds keep going to
insured through a framework called UK
Ledger framework for the partner uh
Partners Alliance and we build contract
that is called IHG
so this was a slide that was shown in
January just confirming that that both
scheme matches uh the 2018 consultation
all right so this is just the new two
counselors and we when we took a
pre-planning consultation with the
community in April
um which the outcomes of uh 95 of people
agree that it sent me the traded
and
most support for the activities
were most popular
and then the majority respondents were
being under the proposals
this is how the development is for both
safe place and what is outside
so you can see in the gray box
there the gray box there is the retained
support for the front of the site here
is the existing facility stream in June
which will be attained
during construction
s of both compounds and the new facility
you can see here
on towards the center of the sides
this is the main facility
um and the layout on site which is in
planning at the moment
and
key points are I think it's not about 3D
football pitch so the
football Foundation from the 3D football
which is
this is where the existing is which will
become car parking and then uh the
spelling out
um of the center is going into the
department
was a bad relationship between the
building and the park setting
and I just built on that uh this is the
park setting in its entirety
um and without knowing Society it's it's
easy enough you know to see all the
sports network is that supported by the
center and as well as the low sensors
there you've got the following reasons
the football pictures the pistols and
the installation of
um
women cycling circuits
this is the proposed ground for all of
us I don't suppose to go into any detail
key points to notice that there's an
area of space for
um Chester Royal hospital so that's the
paper plus Clinic that is currently
located in bankruptcy relocated within
the facility and it's similarly citizens
advice to your own located in the
facility as well
the ground flows lies the center around
the heart of the building which the
cafes play
um
this is the upstairs of the facility uh
where you've got a large thing of Suite
um studio and key point is coming in the
medium facility so that's assisted
um
population
together
here are some index advantages of the
summit which themselves
this is how the side boxing in a second
please get elevations uh showing some of
the finishes on the right hand side
there so we'll try and finish and the
brick finishes
income here
um
so this isn't here would you walk into
reception
um a walk through which is the next
slide which is
a quick walk around with approaches
okay so this is where I walked into
reception area
yoga
and then we'll walk through with the
satisfy on the left hand side
on the right hand side there is
the heart of the facilitated Cafe
and towards the
um
there we go so you can see the pool hold
out in the cafe so this is walking out
to
The Parkside
Cafe is the key to the facility
walking through now and felt tires
breathe in here
over a PV pool
and then we go this is where the gym and
the CBS faces
a very large camera and that will be the
biggest
reception area and also
in a minute I'll look in the park
so this is a great sense
you can see that
obviously not going to exactly
so this is on the four hall gallery
accuracy
so that is a proposal from the ground to
the entrance of the site into the
building
[Music]
a low carbon is a big
consideration
it's it comes to actually planned from
as well
a lot of carbon Technologies and there's
a new build that's been designed using
being green
and then that's how that sounds like
sometimes itself
while we're here today so we are getting
to the points where the council will
have all costs and packages to review
that would be in November 16th
and then the anticipation is starting on
site in January
2014 with
um
the SAT itself so if you remember going
through on the first slide of the
completion of the new facility culture
of the existing and then denomination of
the exits
that will be excited
um
again that I'll go so heat up the social
value elements for the contract which is
this is the side of how it relates to
take off and the rest of the plan deal
Investments
and then there's a summer age
thank you for the presentation
applications I'm sure it's included
yes
okay
um councilor reader
um
a brilliant facility
um well obviously it's part of the
consultation you know but currently at
Sean Park would also report the exam
facility
can you confirm what the depth of that
ball is and you know from that
consultation what what came out of those
discussions with that sorting problem
where they're where they're going to be
thank you
and so the depth of some important
there was conversations
[Music]
swimming pool
so the conversations
thrown around the Sun at which there was
too many depth so I wanted to
suggestions
there is also the
um requests of sport England for the
additional funding today
we've got movable floor so that can get
a free new depth and then similarly as
we've said in conversation people have
three disposed in the district so if it
is Affordable
um
[Music]
uh
foreign
they don't know where to go we're coming
in coming out of time well I like to
look at is something from the hospital
the way way out not weighing where I've
got going on and I went to that big
it gives an accident I think that when
somebody will eventually and also across
the world from this again and it's going
to be announcing nine hours as well so
we're very full size now we'll have a
four-way situation
foreign
[Music]
as well
and
[Music]
similar we have start engaged in the
coming dangerous
bchs around Pentecost Clinic they are
willing to
provide pedestrian access from the site
and they are willing to provide need for
Access into that car park but we will be
able they are not willing to provide an
access to the facility through their
table team access
so that leads users
and then
yeah
um
regulations
when we sign up at this is
a talk about the library important to
this is that not taking place that's the
library saying where it is
so yeah there was lots of discussions
about
um why we're being in there one of the
wonderful excitements
the situation with the library
um was the Dutch County Council and the
third two rules that Library
into the Town Center not to the sports
facility and then similarly the initial
cutting that we did included library and
Albert education and Facilities
of 30 million pounds so it from Bubble
salad from the budgetary perspective
Council when it wasn't their favorite
option however garbage can canceled
relocating the library within the
campaign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
but